given that oil and even coal are a
finite resource it doesn't seem to make
sense that we would run that experiment
when we have to get off them anyway
because they're simply finite the result
is that a steady increase in the carbon
in the atmosphere and in the ocean which
doesn't look like much if you look at it
on this chart but when looked at in the
context of of History it actually looks
like this so the carbon parts per
million has really been bouncing around
the 300 level for around 10 million
years and then the last few hundred
years it went into a vertical climb this
is the the essence of the problem this
is very unusual
and and a very very extreme threat as
you can see from from this rate of
growth then this is accompanied by a
temperature increase as one would expect
and this temperature increase if people
talk about two degrees or three degrees
it's important to appreciate just how
sensitive the climate actually is to uh
to temperature small changes result in
huge effects the sensitivity of the
climate is extremely extremely high
we've Amplified this sensitivity by
building our cities right on the on the
coastline most people live very close to
the ocean that some countries of course
that are very low lying and would be
completely underwater in the climate
crisis so we've essentially designed
civilization to be super sensitive to
climate change the important thing to
appreciate is that we are going to exit
the fossil fuels era so it is it is
inevitable that we will exit the
phosphology era because at a certain
point we'll simply run out of carbon to
mine and burn the question is really
when when do we exit the error.f the
goal is to exit the error as quickly as
possible the laws of Economics will
drive
it will drive civilization towards
sustainable energy inevitably people
tend to think like why should electric
vehicles have a subsidy but they're not
taking into account that all fossil fuel
burning Vehicles fundamentally are
subsidized by the cost the environmental
cost to Earth but nobody's paying for it
we are going to pay for it obviously in
the future we'll pay for it electric
airplane isn't necessary right now
electric cars are important stationary
storage of energy is important these
things are much more important than
creating electric supersonic VTOL also
the planes naturally you really want
that gravitational energy density for an
aircraft and this is improving over time
so you know it's important that we
accelerate the transition to sustainable
energy
that's why electric cars it matters
whether electric cars happen sooner or
later you know we're really playing the
crazy game here with the atmosphere of
the oceans
we are taking vast amounts of carbon
from deep underground putting this neat
in the atmosphere this is crazy
we should not do this
it's very dangerous that means we need
to move from the old goal with a
pre-industrial growl goal which was to
move from chopping down forests and
killing lots of whales
that the old goal was to move from
chopping wood and and killing whales to
fossil fuels which is actually in that
context was a good thing but the new
goal is to move to a sustainable energy
future
and we want to use things like Hydro
solar wind geothermal nuclear is also a
good option in places like France which
don't aren't subject to natural
disasters and we want to use energy
sources that will be good for for a
billion years the more carbon we take
out of the ground and add to the
atmosphere and a lot of it gets
permeated into the oceans the more
dangerous it is like I I don't think
right now I think we're okay right now
we can probably even add some more but
the momentum towards sustainable energy
is too slow there's a vast base of
Industry
vast transportation system like those
two and a half billion cars and trucks
in the world the new car and truck
production if it was a hundred percent
electric that's only about 100 million
per year so it would take if you could
snap your fingers
and instantly turn all cars and trucks
electric it would still take 25 years to
change the transport base to Electric
the scientific scientific consensus is
overwhelming overwhelming I mean I don't
know any serious science it's actually
zero literally zero who who don't think
that we will have quite a serious
climate risk that we're facing and so
there's fundamentally a subsidy
occurring with every fossil fuel burning
thing or all fossil fuel powered things
have an inherent subsidy which is their
consumption of the carbon capacity of
the atmosphere an ocean I look at the
future from a standpoint of the
probabilities it's like a branching
stream of probabilities and there are
actions that we can take that affect
those probabilities
or that accelerate one thing or slow
down another thing you know introduce
something new to the probability stream
the fundamental value of a company like
Tesla is the degree to which it
accelerates the Advent of sustainable
energy faster than it would otherwise
occur so when I think like what is the
fundamental good of kind of like Tesla I
would say hopefully if it accelerated
that by a decade potentially more than a
decade that would be quite a good thing
to occur that's what I consider to be
the fundamental sort of aspirational
good of Tesla gather tax for the um you
know to pay for the federal government
we should shift the tax boom to to bad
things and then adjust the tax of that
bad thing according to whatever is going
to result in the behavior that we think
is beneficial for the future you know
what we're doing right now which is
Mining and burning trillions of tons of
hydrocarbons that used to be buried very
deep underground and now we're sticking
them in the atmosphere and writing this
crazy chemical experiment on the
atmosphere and then you've got the oil
and gas companies which have ungodly
amounts of money and you can't expect
them to just roll over and die like they
don't do that what is the system that
will result in the most amount of good
for the most amount of people like what
maximizes the area under the curve of
population happiness like often people
say well like the government should do
it but really what is the government but
a corporation in the limit so is the
government going to do so do the right
thing if when it isn't monopolistic
Corporation
unlikely if the government is not is
essentially not not the solution I know
I think we just want to take the set of
actions that accelerate the transition
to a sustainable energy economy and
that's sustainable energy economy is
going to be like I said primarily solar
with wind you absolutely need stationary
storage batteries because of the
intermittency of solar and wind and then
then there will also be hydroelectric
geothermal nuclear these are all fine
and the common but we want to just move
as quickly as we can to a sort of a
solar electric economy and sometimes
people say oh it's cloudy or something
what about solar and since you plan to
grow there are solar powered chemical
reaction If plants grow you have solar
power obviously how do you think they
grow I have a message for the climate
change Skeptics and the Big Oil
people well as first climate change
skeptic I mean like I'm you know I like
to I believe in the scientific method
and one should be one should have a
healthy skepticism of things in general
and what do you think the percentage
chance is of of this being catastrophic
for some meaningful percentage of those
population
is it greater than one percent is it
even one percent
um if it is even one percent why are we
running this experiment so the obvious
solution here is a common tax now uh
over time I'm confident we will have
this um and if you just put the common
tax in place everything will be fine
it's the thing that that should be done
very terrible situation but he also said
it's not like there's no good that comes
out of even a terrible situation there's
some good that comes out of it but it's
overwhelmingly bad it's just really
interesting to read about history learn
the lessons of History such that we do
not repeat mistakes of the past but I
want to be clear I like I'm not trying
to be anyone's savior uh I'm just trying
to think about the future and not be sad
[Music]